I might get emotional again delivery
beginning baby no no really I got a in
the wedding or something to do this to
drill away not now I think this for the
mouth see I know okay I want to stop
talking I need a I need mature Oh from
about yeah is it what are you going to
do whenever someone's going to take back
with you all right so what's they open
up my zipper it goes through my things
they get a same point camera when they
try to get it you'd be on duty and then
they probably hit me I'll give it out
and then last but I take all away camera
was walking talk walk and talk your son
is in self-defense mode I know I love it
a breeze you will good morning morning
from beautiful Teddy another beautiful
day we are on our way to ok we're
crossing the street there are we
shopping in the street sign down here
yeah it sounds like so we're on our way
to go to the Eiffel Tower but on the way
there we're going to see we bump into a
little cafe and get some coffee if I
finally eat a French clothes long cuz we
haven't done that yet so that's the goal
for today excited baby yeah you've been
wanting to go yeah you ever wanted to go
see the Eiffel Tower this whole time yes
he's good actors
[Music]
all right so something we're looking for
right now is a place where we can get
bakery items like to respond but
unfortunately Parisians don't really do
breakfast you know typically eat into
lunch oh we found one very hot
[Music]
allocation er I think there's like the
real it's hot chocolate you're going to
ever get in your life you know that
powder I can't really get a home yeah
that's the fake stuff I think this is
real chocolate
[Music]
like the ice if it is bed see my school
course on time a good where we get you
try wheel for chocolate I know we've
been here for about three days now still
haven't had an omelet so I haven't had a
croissant and those are two Americans
that leaves the most fundamental of
French cuisine I guess you'll earn that
upscale omelet you learn how to get a
croissant you learning which that is the
kids so the following eating for common
Alma today exciting taste like butter
very nice lunch Microsoft and milk even
though all that was good
is you're trying to eat yeah all right
time for me to make this food its appeal
all right I took the first bite they
know how to cook eggs Americans love to
overcook their eggs and not have it
running
you only got one side and then turn
multiplier and Netanya and how you cook
it so I don't like cake so I don't like
any omelet anything about it comes good
are you thinking high off by not now bro
I feel like I have so yeah you're
forever faithful at school
loyalty
[Music]
so it's been a shouting breakfast and
now we're on our way to the Eiffel Tower
thank you really do I useful sound the
moment you've been waiting for how long
you been waiting for this like really
[Music]
all right we're finally yeah I'm so
happy I finally get to see it in person
after all this wedding planning you like
running walking in circles
every time you like whatever we're going
to try to get up to the top and see all
of petit four up this beautiful Eiffel
Tower
hi Sally sight let's see what it looks
like right underneath it
we're going to it's fun dance right here
Casey falls again but of the Eiffel
Tower here on the Casey do be real here
[Music]
all right hey
based on the pickpocket - I wouldn't be
here because I don't want to pay a fee
to come in to pick talkin your vital
power amazing spirit all in every night
oh boy he can dizzy a lot you're not
going to get Jimmy she's really scared
of rice I go on circles of you really
scared of going like that so vivid I
regret maybe watching the stomach not a
baby anymore no I'm a baby
there's my baby he's having the time I
smell that fresh air i'm karis girl
you're in Paris this is crazy
keep sinking in just lonely now that
work here
ow barely touching it look he is joining
my entire head consistory I think I'm
gonna get your head stuck
especially me of course what it look
like out there I could do that with my
camera oh really oh oh you're not
weakened it Hey look get on a field trip
all right together all wearing the same
hat all right walk downstairs yes do it
we are now walking to the Eiffel Tower
dippers waiting for the elevator to go
down to front and rates are down it's
crazy because uh we're seeing people
coming up and we're going down and
they're right way out of breath but four
gravities on our side so hopefully we
don't get too tired from this
[Music]
maybe we make it right I think you tired
no hey mom I said I'm background yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
shame
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'll carry a lot all these different
places and I actually come here and
visit them crazy I think Paris is the
one city that I really heard a lot about
and as far as I can ever remember my
entire life compressed in any other city
in the world so it's really cool to
finally be here and experience it and
have Isaac experience that with me -
it's really beautiful it's really
awesome you think
remember I think it's kind of like going
in one ear enough the other kind of
thing or is kind of like oh cool and
then but once we leave here that's what
it's really going to hit him just like
Japan where Japan and get something
enjoy it we're here you never know where
you really come back not until we went
back home that's when he's really like
was missing in he was talking about it
I'm guessing that's the same thing
that's going to happen in here but
luckily for him we're going to be coming
back a few months to the wedding so
he'll be able to experience it all over
again all right keep it ringing al I
know why Brian but frame also had beer
[Music]
what is that our duck side banana banana
split if some say 100 that don't
[Music]
hey for a guy that doesn't like telling
the cigarette smoke that out here in
Europe you love imitating it yeah like
over in Japan and we went to Mount Fuji
you can't feel so cold there you could
be your friend so you kept doing it I'm
like weird you learned that like a kid's
day you know what's so mean okay let's
bring all those I remember you told me
that when I was a kid in the cold you
will be like you told me that now China
you think that your mother
yeah it's ironic cuz Isaac's got this
big problem with all the smoke that's
out here in Europe smoking cigarette
it's not a taboo thing like it is in the
States over Isaac its people it's like a
huge culture shock for him he's all like
every time you smell that he's like oh
my gosh we chose to sit outside right
now so smoke being blown every which
direction to us and so it's ironic that
he's actually retaining the smoke
cigarette while eating a banana split
[Music]
[Music]
what is he doing
carrying himself out before perfect I
know before scary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is
[Music]
okay trauma ties now so why you why you
wiping into your hair why is your hair
oh you're gonna take a shower wing as I
call man this place is cool I wanna come
from traveling these are the countryside
like in the cut
[Music]
I want my crown back you're handling
food streets the guy food out gotta look
at all the food places on the map we get
all your the guy sick que la calle de la
comida nice he's good you know way more
sense
oh yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]
sorry now we're just kind of getting
lost a little bit no we're not actually
lost we're just exploring the area near
no TRADOC and then we're going to get on
the Metro head over to the Apple Tower
hopefully get on a cruise and maybe have
some dinner later but this alley right
here is smells amazing
oh my god I wish I could have just as
well as this alley in the jar and be
able to smell it whatever it was
smells amazing gotta come back to this
alley when we're like really hungry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are now on just send crews we finally
made it I think this is a very last
cruise of the night so luckily we're
able to make it to the left roof we went
upstairs where they call open and it
doesn't seem to be any seats but
hopefully right now we'll call
apparently there's anything that opened
up back I guess not because multiple
opportunity back it is finding no space
but not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
so we're having dinner now is restaurant
where we were walking earlier in the Le
I'm pretty tired at the end of the day
I'm pretty excited about this one just
because brig are doing on do oh you're
doing steak you're doing steak a key
I don't know how you pronounce it stay
catching as he ordered so speak English
knows well I'm glad I think been able to
find things that you like to eat here
because that was one of our biggest
concerns
he's very limited and type of food that
you want to venture into and so luckily
both their Steak and Shake is a very
familiar thing for you English not an
effeminate who's opposed a he's learned
i said english haha yeah well he said
anyways I'm excited about the fondue
because I never had fun here before
we're not doing cheese fondue we are
doing oil that for me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right I've got a couple bites now
this is awesome this is a really awesome
experience it's really like shabu shabu
quick stuff instead of water we got oil
I guess traditionally what Americans
know as fondue it's usually cheese so
where you can oil and often they even
give you a little chicken stock used to
do are we were done eating and now I'm
drop the flame over now a lot traveling
is my eating right yeah I love eating if
you don't eat when you travel you are
not traveling properly it's an etiquette
to eat in travel people will be busy all
right so we're back home now it is one
am it's way past your bedtime little boy
I am home
what do you mean no don't that back to
me I saw your phone is 12
like 1257 are you really wait wait okay
anyways so we're back home now and it's
one am yes what would you guys think of
today pretty good pretty good so finally
I think you guys have all the wedding
machines you know figure out decisions
are made but I think it's kind of
awkward and when you call me mr. chair I
clearly papa can patch in okay see I
didn't call you mr. Chen yeah kind of
awkward why did I work were yeah
so do you think it's time to make a
change no you want to way into the day
off hey can we ask you this just so
agree because I've actually been wanting
the toy as long as that for a long time
oh my gosh I'm getting emotional
oh yeah because I really love you bye
okay but I just um I guess I held back
from that because you guys felt more
comfortable with me calling you guys mr.
mrs. Chan so I would thought maybe until
the time comes when we get married and
that would happen so it means a lot to
me that you think you owe me one thank
you now have a go - I gained a daughter
this beautiful daughter and a grandson
yeah so what are you gonna call me Debra
oh man then you will call him yeah yeah
yeah yeah
in Cantonese is this funny gonna be so
funny no no that's a Cantonese much
boring how he said oh ho yeah old man
partner yeah and just two old old and
the thing is too old - perfect
I'll call you Jackie get the sign my
gosh ha ha Wylie what is that sorry what
my girl good dogged organic good oh boy
would that be appropriate no smell no
contest don't you yes yes
[Music]
can you reach Oh clay whoo here judge to
fight each other they got in there gosh
give me a cable attack I just compared
to LA for a smoke again oh very smoke
ative minute we are heading out now
we're going to be going to Versailles
[Music]